This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. When Saru Najarian was about 10, his pastime was collecting baseball and basketball cards. These were hard to come by in Cyprus where he grew up. So when Saru's cousin pestured him to share his cards with her, he always said no. But she didn't give up. As she pestered and begged and pleaded, it came to a boiling point where I got so angry that everything blacked out and I slapped her really hard.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔。萨鲁·纳贾里安大约10岁时，他的爱好是收集棒球和篮球卡。在他长大的塞浦路斯，这些卡片很难弄到。所以当萨鲁的表妹缠着他分享卡片时，他总是拒绝。但她没有放弃。随着她不断地纠缠、哀求和恳求，事情到了爆发点，我变得非常愤怒，以至于大脑一片空白，狠狠地扇了她一巴掌。
Saro's arm seemed to act of its own volition. A second later, I came back into the reality and I saw her crying and had no idea what had done. Hala Reed experienced something similar at the same age. She was a budding environmentalist with a peace ecology flag hanging on her bedroom wall. One afternoon, she heard the cracking of trees and a low rumble.
萨鲁的手臂似乎有了自己的意志。一秒钟后，我回到了现实，看到她在哭，完全不知道自己做了什么。哈拉·里德在同样的年纪也经历过类似的事情。她是一位初露头角的环保主义者，卧室墙上挂着一面和平生态旗。一天下午，她听到了树木断裂的声音和低沉的隆隆声。
She realized that her neighbor was knocking down trees to build himself a shorter driveway. He was using a bulldozer. This neighbor came up the road in the bulldozer and was pushing over trees and something in my head just snapped. Paula's dad had got a machete in his travels to South America. Without thinking, Paula sees the weapon. Its blade was about as long as her arm. In shorts and bare feet, she climbed up on the bulldozer and swung the blade. Metal struck metal. As Paula rained down blows the bulldozer stopped, then retreated. Paula chased after it, cutting ribbons in the air with the machete.
她意识到邻居为了修一条更短的车道正在砍树。他用的是推土机。这个邻居开着推土机沿着路过来，推倒了树木，我脑子里有什么东西突然断了。保拉的父亲在去南美旅行时带回了一把大砍刀。保拉想都没想就抓住了武器。刀刃和她的手臂差不多长。她穿着短裤，赤着脚，爬上推土机，挥动了刀刃。金属撞击金属。随着保拉不断挥砍，推土机停了下来，然后后退。保拉追了上去，用大砍刀在空中划出一道道痕迹。
in the air with the machete. I have no idea where that came from, but I was in a complete wild red rage. Today on the show, wild, red rage. The moments when we suddenly snap, an animal furies erupt within us. Such rage can harm others. It can harm us. It's easy to think we'd be better off without such wrath. But as blind as uncontrollable anger can be, it turns out, we would be worse off without it.
在空中挥舞着大砍刀。我不知道那股劲儿是从哪儿来的，但我当时处于一种完全狂野、愤怒的状态。今天节目的话题就是：狂野、愤怒。那些我们突然失控、内心爆发野兽般狂怒的时刻。这种愤怒会伤害他人，也会伤害我们自己。我们很容易认为没有这种愤怒会更好。但事实证明，尽管无法控制的愤怒可能让人盲目，但如果没有它，我们的处境会更糟。
The deep logic of irrational rage, this week on Hidden Brain. This is the story of a woman who snapped. I would say that I'm a gentle person, and that's me putting it optimistically. Just Cavendor always thought of herself as a timid person. Timid? To the point of pushover. My brother wasn't shy about telling me that I was a dormant for most of my life, and I didn't want to see myself as a dormant, but I also didn't have evidence to the contrary. In elementary school, for example, Jess saved up years of pocket
非理性愤怒背后的深层逻辑，本周《Hidden Brain》。这是一个关于一个女人失控的故事。我会说我是一个温柔的人，这还是乐观的说法。杰斯·卡文多一直认为自己是个胆小的人。胆小？胆小到任人摆布。我哥哥毫不客气地告诉我，我这辈子大部分时间都是个软柿子，我不想把自己看作软柿子，但我也没有证据反驳。例如，在小学时，杰斯攒了多年的零花钱
money and birthday cash, storing her savings in a music box. Her dream? A much coveted trampoline. Finally, one day, she had enough money. She and her dad drove to Sam's club. I bought this trampoline and I was so excited. Until her trampoline was taken over by intruders. My two siblings, my older brother and young sister, would bounce on the trampoline as well and sometimes I couldn't get it to myself the way I'd like it. Jess' siblings didn't just hog the trampoline.
和生日红包，把积蓄存在一个音乐盒里。她的梦想？一个梦寐以求的蹦床。终于有一天，她攒够了钱。她和爸爸开车去了山姆会员店。我买了那个蹦床，当时非常兴奋。直到她的蹦床被入侵者占领。我的两个兄弟姐妹，哥哥和妹妹，也会在蹦床上跳，有时我没法像我想要的那样独自使用它。杰斯的兄弟姐妹不仅霸占了蹦床。
They treated her as if she were an unwelcome guest. Jess tried to get her dad to step in. Instead of helping, he offered her some advice. My dad suggested to me that I, you know, charge them to use the trampoline, since it was my trampoline, and I had done all the work to say for it that I should charge them a fee to use it.
他们对待她就像对待一个不受欢迎的客人。杰斯试图让爸爸介入。但他没有帮忙，反而给了她一些建议。我爸爸建议我，你知道，向他们收取使用蹦床的费用，因为那是我的蹦床，而且我付出了所有的努力才攒够钱，所以我应该向他们收费。
He might as well have suggested she punched someone in the face. Her siblings didn't even bother arguing with her. They just ignored her. I don't know how I would have ever enforced charging 25 cents for my siblings to use it. They certainly would just be like, no, walk past me and get on the trampoline. Just did not experience the slights with fury. She accepted them with resignation.
他这话简直就像建议她去扇别人耳光一样。她的兄弟姐妹甚至懒得跟她争辩。他们只是无视她。我不知道我该怎么强制要求兄弟姐妹付25美分来使用它。他们肯定会说“不”，然后直接走过我身边跳上蹦床。杰斯并没有因为这些轻视而感到愤怒。她选择了逆来顺受。
Over the years, there were other moments like this, moments that would have sparked anger in some people. But Jess usually kept her cool. Until one night, years later, when she didn't. She was in graduate school, living with two roommates in off-campus housing. It has all of the the trimmings of being sort of college living where you're paying for a lot and not getting very much and people are packed in. Late one night, Jess was jolted awake by a sound. I hear heavy footfalls going down the stairs. Jess immediately thought she knew what had happened.
多年来，还有其他类似的时刻，那些本会在某些人心中激起愤怒的时刻。但杰斯通常保持冷静。直到多年后的一个晚上，她没能忍住。当时她在读研究生，和两个室友住在校外。那里有大学生活的所有特征，你付了很多钱却得不到多少东西，而且人挤人。一天深夜，杰斯被一阵声音惊醒。我听到沉重的脚步声走下楼梯。杰斯立刻以为她知道发生了什么。
Her roommate Kim had torn her Achilles tendon and was wearing a boot. Jess figured that Kim had fallen on the stairs. She leaped out of bed, threw on her robe, and opened her bedroom door. Her other roommate, Shelby, opened her door at the same time. She'd also heard the noise. She's looking at me and I'm looking at her and Kim's not at the bottom of the stairs, so we both just run down the stairs to see what had happened. Well, the both of us arrive at the bottom of the stairs, and a very large man with my kitchen rag held over his face
她的室友金撕裂了跟腱，戴着护具。杰斯以为金在楼梯上摔倒了。她跳下床，披上睡袍，打开卧室门。她的另一个室友谢尔比同时打开了门。她也听到了声音。她看着我，我也看着她，金不在楼梯底部，所以我们俩都跑下楼梯看看发生了什么。好吧，我们俩到达楼梯底部时，一个非常高大的男人用我的厨房抹布蒙着脸
comes wheeling out of the kitchen with a gun pointed at us. The first thing Jess took in about the man was his size. He was at least six foot five. He was about a head taller than she was. All I could see was his eyes. The square of his eyes were yellow. And aside from that, really I was staring at the barrel of the gun. The man yelled, where's the money? Get the money. Go upstairs. Standing there in her
从厨房冲出来，用枪指着我们。杰斯对这个男人的第一印象是他的体型。他至少有6英尺5英寸高。他比她高出一个头。我只能看到他的眼睛。他的眼白是黄色的。除此之外，我真的只是盯着枪管。那个男人大喊：“钱在哪？把钱拿出来。上楼去。”站在那里的她
robe, with a gun pointed at her head, just did not snap. Instead, her mind became cool and analytical. What could she do to get out of the situation? Out of the corner of her eye, she noticed a movement. Another man had emerged from a side room. And I know that they want something valuable, and I have nothing. I'm aware that I have no cash. I have no TV screens. The man with a gun, motioned for the two women to go up the stairs, presumably to fetch their wallets. Shelby, normally a ball of energy, had gone still.
穿着睡袍，被枪指着头，杰斯并没有失控。相反，她的头脑变得冷静而理智。她能做什么来摆脱这种局面？眼角余光中，她注意到有动静。另一个男人从侧面的房间里出来。我知道他们想要值钱的东西，但我什么都没有。我知道我没有现金。我没有电视机。那个拿枪的男人示意两个女人上楼，大概是去拿钱包。谢尔比平时是个充满活力的人，此刻却僵住了。
I discovered that she's frozen. She isn't blinking, she's not looking at me, she's not moving. So I put my hand on her back and I say everything's gonna be okay. We're going upstairs, just give them what they want. As Jess and Shelby climb the stairs, the robbers came up behind them. One of the guys puts his hand on my butt to like push me and that's when It occurred to me that something sexually violent might happen Still Jess felt no rage the second robber took Shelby into her room the first man the one with a gun
我发现她冻住了。她不眨眼，不看我，也不动。所以我把手放在她背上说，一切都会好起来的。我们上楼去，给他们想要的就行。当杰斯和谢尔比爬上楼梯时，劫匪跟在她们身后。其中一个人把手放在我的屁股上推我，就在那时，我意识到可能会发生性暴力。尽管如此，杰斯仍然没有感到愤怒。第二个劫匪把谢尔比带进了她的房间，第一个拿枪的男人
Followed Jess into her bedroom and The first man, the one with a gun, followed Jess into her bedroom. And he's yelling, get on the bed. And that's when the sort of thought, there's no way in hell that I will get on this bed, not for anything. It's a second story building. I probably would have jumped out of the window before I actually got on the bed. Jess kept thinking, what could she give the man to make him leave? And I'm looking around my room, and I'm looking for something of value. I have stacks of books, I have dance clothes, I have all sorts of things that could not possibly, in my mind, register giving to him. I'm just looking around for something valuable
跟着杰斯进了她的卧室。第一个拿枪的男人跟着杰斯进了她的卧室。他大喊：“趴到床上。”就在那一刻，我心想，我绝不可能趴到这张床上，绝对不行。这是二楼。我可能在趴到床上之前就跳窗逃跑了。杰斯一直在想，她能给这个男人什么让他离开？我环顾四周，寻找有价值的东西。我有成堆的书，有跳舞的衣服，还有各种各样在我看来不可能给他的东西。我只是在寻找有价值的东西
to give to him so that he will leave. And I look down and I see my camera. The camera she used for work. Now, my camera is the main way that I provide for myself and that's how I was making enough money to really to feed myself. And so that represented to me my livelihood, my survival. I had a split second emotional response to it, thinking no, he doesn't get that. And that's when everything changed. Just it not snap when two men invaded her home. She didn't snap when one of them touched her.
给他，好让他离开。我低头看到了我的相机。那是她工作用的相机。我的相机是我维持生计的主要工具，也是我赚取足够钱来养活自己的方式。所以那对我来说代表着我的生计，我的生存。我对此产生了一瞬间的情绪反应，心想：不，他不能拿走那个。就在那时，一切都变了。杰斯在两个男人闯入她家时没有失控。当其中一个人碰她时，她没有失控。
She didn't snap when she was forced at gunpoint into her bedroom and told to get on the bed. But when she realized the robber might take her camera? That's when I realized this person has no right to come in here and to demand my things, or to even be in my space. That was really the first time that I had a strong response to this person violating me.
当她被枪指着被迫进入卧室并被要求趴在床上时，她没有失控。但当她意识到劫匪可能会拿走她的相机时？就在那时，我意识到这个人没有权利闯进来要求得到我的东西，甚至没有权利进入我的空间。那真的是我第一次对这个侵犯我的人产生了强烈的反应。
I looked at the gun, just squarely faced him in a way that I don't think I've ever done to anyone and said, get out. Get out of my house. You do not belong here. Jess could hear the man's accomplice in the other room shouting, shoot her. Shoot her. Jess spotted her cell phone. She grabbed it. The robber saw what she was doing. And as I got my hand on it, he jumped on top of me and we're rolling on the floor fighting each other. He's using one hand to try and pry the cell phone out and I'm using the same hand that's on the cell phone to dig my fingernails into his skin and then the other hand to try and pry the gun out of his hand.
我盯着那把枪，以一种我想我从未对任何人做过的方式直视着他，说：“滚出去。滚出我的房子。你不属于这里。”杰斯能听到那个男人的同伙在另一个房间大喊：“开枪打死她！开枪打死她！”杰斯发现了她的手机。她抓住了它。劫匪看到了她的动作。当我抓住它时，他扑到我身上，我们在地板上翻滚打斗。他用一只手试图抢走手机，我用抓着手机的那只手把指甲抠进他的皮肤里，另一只手试图把枪从他手里夺走。
hand to try and pry the gun out of his hand. Something primal, stirred inside Jess. She was suddenly consumed by blinding rage. His chest is on my back, his arms are around my arms. He's completely sort of crouched over and around me as we're, you know, falling on our sides and I'm kicking and scratching and... The ones are flooding her mind, not survival. Don't let him win. Somehow that mattered.
试图把枪从他手里夺走。某种原始的东西在杰斯内心激荡。她突然被盲目的愤怒所吞噬。他的胸口压在我的背上，他的手臂环绕着我的手臂。当我们倒在地上时，他完全蜷缩在我身上，我踢着、抓着……那些念头充斥着她的脑海，不是生存。别让他赢。不知何故，这很重要。
I was using every ounce of my physical strength and not caring that I was inflicting pain and actually being like, that's fine. That's the point. If to get this phone back out of his hand. I don't know why, I was more focused on the phone than the gun but I was. The second robber barged into the bedroom. They were not two of them in the room, but she had no thought for risk or danger. Something new had taken over. I just started screaming.
我用尽了全身的力气，根本不在乎我是否在造成痛苦，甚至觉得：没关系，这就是目的。为了把手机从他手里夺回来。我不知道为什么，我比关注枪更关注手机，但我确实如此。第二个劫匪闯进了卧室。房间里现在有两个人了，但她完全没有考虑风险或危险。某种新的东西接管了她。我开始尖叫。
I... full on high pitch, blood curling... screech of a scream. And apparently my scream was so loud that I woke up one neighbor who was wearing headphones
我……发出了一种高音调、令人毛骨悚然的尖叫声。显然我的尖叫声太大了，以至于吵醒了一个戴着耳机的邻居
and then the other neighbor who was asleep on the other side. The men were so startled by the screams that they took off. One grabbed Jess's laptop on his way out. Jess's scream woke up her other roommate. Unbelievably, Kim had slept through the whole thing. And she opened the door and says, you know, what's wrong? I was like, call the police."
然后是睡在另一边的邻居。男人们被尖叫声吓坏了，于是逃跑了。其中一个在离开时抢走了杰斯的笔记本电脑。杰斯的尖叫声吵醒了她的另一个室友。令人难以置信的是，金竟然睡过了整个过程。她打开门说：“怎么了？”我说：“报警。”
In that moment, Jess Cavendor, who had lived her life as a timid person, had no sense that she had acted out of character. All that unfolded was in no way, shape, or form unnatural or surprising to me in the moment. It was what needed to happen. I wasn't surprised at myself until, but later when I was like, I cannot for the life of me believe that I looked at a guy who's holding a gun at my head
那一刻，一直以胆小自居的杰斯·卡文多，完全没有意识到自己的行为反常。发生的一切在当时对我来说一点也不反常，也不令人惊讶。那是必须发生的事情。我直到后来才对自己感到惊讶，当时我想，我简直不敢相信我竟然盯着一个拿枪指着我头的家伙
and decided that I was gonna yell at him. Or fight. Yeah, or fight. Jess's story reveals a strange truth about our capacity for fury. It often arrives without warning. It seems to have a mind of its own. We can ignore serious provocations for years, and then, boom, we snap. Only later do we look back at our actions in wonder. When we come back, understanding the triggers that can push even the most mild manner Stay with us.
并决定对他大喊大叫。或者反抗。是的，或者反抗。杰斯的故事揭示了一个关于我们愤怒能力的奇怪真相。它往往毫无预兆地到来。它似乎有自己的思想。我们可以多年无视严重的挑衅，然后，砰的一声，我们失控了。只有在事后，我们才会惊奇地回顾自己的行为。当我们回来时，了解那些能让最温和的人也爆发的触发点。请继续收听。
A defining quality of wild, red rage is that it often comes out of nowhere. It takes over our minds and deprives us of reason and logic. When Jess Cavendor lost it and literally fought a robber who had a gun pointed at her head, she took a very serious risk. She and her roommates could have ended up dead. In retrospect, you could say it was foolhardy and irrational. All this presents a mystery. It's taken millions of years of evolution to produce the human brain. It has an exquisite capacity for reason and logic. Why would natural selection install a circuit breaker to undermine our capacity for logical thinking? Doug Fields has long puzzled over this question.
狂野、愤怒的一个显著特征是它往往来得毫无征兆。它占据了我们的头脑，剥夺了我们的理智和逻辑。当杰斯·卡文多失去理智，真的与一个拿枪指着她头的劫匪搏斗时，她冒了很大的风险。她和她的室友本可能丧命。回想起来，你可以说这是鲁莽和非理性的。这一切提出了一个谜题。人类大脑的进化历经数百万年。它拥有卓越的理智和逻辑能力。为什么自然选择会安装一个断路器来破坏我们的逻辑思维能力？道格·菲尔兹长期以来一直对这个问题感到困惑。
His interest in rage grows out of his fascination with the brain, but it's also based on an unforgettable personal experience. The story he told me has the ring of a Hollywood thriller, but with a catch. Doug, our leading man, is not a muscle bound hero. He's a neuroscientist, and not just any neuroscientist, but a walking stereotype of a neuroscientist and not just any neuroscientist, but a walking stereotype of a neuroscientist. Here's his daughter, Kelly Fields. Like, we'd be watching a movie together
他对愤怒的兴趣源于他对大脑的痴迷，但也基于一次难忘的个人经历。他告诉我的故事听起来像好莱坞惊悚片，但有一个转折。道格，我们的主角，不是肌肉发达的英雄。他是一位神经科学家，而且不仅仅是普通的神经科学家，还是神经科学家的典型代表。这是他的女儿，凯利·菲尔兹。比如，我们一起看电影
and there's some sort of car accident or some big scene going on and he'll just sort of chime in and be like, wow, you can't see the shadow behind that plant in the corner anymore. Did you notice that they changed the lighting for no reason, even though it's the same scene, and I would be like, no, actually, I was watching the car accident. So yeah, just a very sort of typical nerd. Doug is 5'7 and weighs maybe 135 pounds. Glasses, thin hair.
出现某种车祸或大场面时，他会插嘴说：“哇，你再也看不到那个角落植物后面的影子了。你注意到他们无缘无故地改变了灯光吗，尽管是同一个场景？”我会说：“不，其实我是在看车祸。”所以，他就是一个非常典型的书呆子。道格身高5英尺7英寸，体重可能只有135磅。戴着眼镜，头发稀疏。
Don't think of Sean Connery or Matt Damon. You got to think of Woody Allen here. In 2007, Doug was scheduled to go to Barcelona to present some research at a neuroscience conference. He decided to turn a work trip into a father-daughter vacation and took Kelly with him. She was 17, he was 57. Their first stop was Paris. Waiting in line to the Eiffel Tower, Kelly got a new glimpse into how her dad's mind worked. A couple came up to us and were speaking perfect English with American accents and they
别想肖恩·康纳利或马特·达蒙。你得想伍迪·艾伦。2007年，道格计划去巴塞罗那参加一个神经科学会议并发表研究报告。他决定把工作旅行变成父女度假，带上了凯利。她17岁，他57岁。他们的第一站是巴黎。在埃菲尔铁塔排队时，凯利对她父亲的思维方式有了新的认识。一对夫妇走近我们，用带有美国口音的完美英语交谈，他们
were very nice and I just noticed they were standing too close to us. I kept glancing behind us sort of like, why are you standing so close? And I noticed this woman's hand near his pants and then I look again and I noticed his pocket is unzipped and I just sort of whispered to my dad I think they're trying to rob you Doug was completely unfazed My dad informed me that that was a decoy wallet Your dad had a decoy wallet You are just as surprised as I was I was like what?
非常友好，我只是注意到他们站得离我们太近了。我不断地向后看，心想：他们为什么要站得这么近？然后我注意到这个女人的手靠近他的裤子，我再看一眼，发现他的口袋拉链没拉，我就悄悄对爸爸说：“我觉得他们想抢劫你。”道格完全没受影响。我爸爸告诉我，那是诱饵钱包。你有诱饵钱包？你和我一样惊讶。我说：“什么？”
You are just as surprised as I was. I was like, what? He had this special wallet that he would keep in his front pocket. It was special because the way it was cut to fit into his front pocket. And that was his wallet. Sorry, I'm blowing all your covers down. And then he had a fake wallet in his back pocket with not a lot of money in it and a few fake credit cards. Doug came up with a strategy many vacations ago. You know when you travel it's a wise idea not to have all your money and credit cards in one place. You know you can get robbed or mugged and so the idea is you know if it's a pick pocket and they get a wallet that's useless that doesn't matter but if you're if you're mugged you can hand them in the wallet or throw it on the ground and run.
你和我一样惊讶。我说：“什么？”他有一个特殊的钱包，放在前口袋里。它很特别，因为剪裁方式适合放在前口袋。那就是他的钱包。抱歉，我把你的秘密都泄露了。然后他在后口袋里放了一个假钱包，里面没多少钱，还有几张假信用卡。道格在很多次度假前就想出了这个策略。你知道，旅行时，把所有的钱和信用卡放在同一个地方是不明智的。你知道你可能会被抢劫，所以如果是个扒手，他们拿走一个没用的钱包也没关系；但如果你被抢劫，你可以把那个钱包交给他们，或者扔在地上然后跑掉。
So that's why I do that. For anyone keeping score, that's Neuroscientist 1, Pickpockets 0. After visiting the Eiffel Tower, father and daughter went back to their hotel and packed their bags. The next day, they took the metro to the airport. Eiffel Tower, father and daughter went back to their hotel and packed their bags. The next day, they took the metro to the airport. This is when Doug broke one of his cardinal rules. I violated my rule of having money in multiple places because TSA makes that difficult when you have to go through inspections.
所以这就是我这样做的原因。对于任何记分的人来说，那是神经科学家1，扒手0。参观完埃菲尔铁塔后，父女俩回到酒店收拾行李。第二天，他们乘地铁去机场。埃菲尔铁塔，父女俩回到酒店收拾行李。第二天，他们乘地铁去机场。就在这时，道格打破了他的一条基本原则。我违反了把钱放在多个地方的原则，因为当你必须通过安检时，运输安全管理局（TSA）会让这变得很困难。
So I figured we're just going to take the ride to the airport, so I had everything in my wallet. Everything in one wallet. We got on the Metro, lots of people. Then we came to a stop, and everybody on the Metro train left. Except one lady who looked very sympathetic at us, and I felt that my wallet was gone. They had lost their money and credit cards. That's neuroscientist one, pickpockets one.
所以我心想我们只是去机场，所以我就把所有东西都放在钱包里了。所有东西都在一个钱包里。我们上了地铁，人很多。然后车停了，地铁上的所有人都离开了。除了一个看起来很同情我们的女士，我感觉到我的钱包不见了。他们丢了钱和信用卡。那是神经科学家1，扒手1。
Doug and Kelly still had their passports, so they were able to get on their flight to Barcelona, where Doug's conference was being held. If you have your wallet stolen in Europe, how do you check into a hotel? What are you going to do? What ultimately happened is I managed to reach my brother in the United States, and he arranged to wire us cash. My brother had picked this place for us to get money, kind of at random on the internet. Doug and Kelly got in a cab and gave the driver the address of the bank where they were to pick up the money.
道格和凯利还有护照，所以他们得以登上了去巴塞罗那的航班，道格的会议就在那里举行。如果你的钱包在欧洲被偷了，你怎么办理酒店入住？你打算怎么办？最终发生的是，我设法联系到了在美国的哥哥，他安排给我们汇款。我哥哥在网上随机选了这个地方让我们取钱。道格和凯利坐上一辆出租车，把银行地址告诉了司机。
Except it wasn't a bank. So we got in a cab, took us way out of the Barcelona tourist area to the most city neighborhood you've ever seen. As vacant shops and trash strewns treats replace sprawling parks and cafes, father and daughter got more and more anxious. Our adrenaline is like coming out our ears already, because we've just been pickpocketed and had all the stress. And we end up in a city part of town at an internet cafe.
但那根本不是银行。所以我们坐上一辆出租车，把我们带出了巴塞罗那的旅游区，到了你见过的最破旧的街区。当空置的商店和垃圾遍地的街道取代了广阔的公园和咖啡馆时，父女俩变得越来越焦虑。我们的肾上腺素已经涌到了嗓子眼，因为我们刚被扒窃，压力很大。我们最终在一个城市部分的网吧里。
And it was just a small dingy building full of really big men basically. The Burley Man was staring at a TV. When Doug and Kelly entered, the men silently turned to watch. Doug went up to the cashier. He gave him this receipt. He reaches in as pocket pulls out this wad of money and starts peeling off you know a thousand dollars or something. And we were just standing there sort of looking at them like are you contacting your friends
那是一个又小又脏的建筑，里面全是看起来很强壮的男人。那个壮汉盯着电视看。当道格和凯利进去时，男人们默默地转过头来看着他们。道格走到收银员面前。他给了他收据。他伸手进兜，掏出一叠钱，开始数出一千美元左右。我们只是站在那里看着他们，心想：你们在联系朋友
to come and rob us? Kellyanne I just know we're going to get robbed again. It was terrible. They didn't get robbed. The cab stayed there, we got in the cab, and then we went back. The next morning, they resolved to put the unpleasantness of the previous days behind them. Doug had to give a talk at the conference that afternoon. In the morning, he and Kelly decided to visit a famous Barcelona cathedral. Now, it would seem like too much bad luck to get robbed again, but...
来抢劫我们吗？凯利和我都知道我们又要被抢了。太可怕了。他们没有被抢。出租车一直停在那儿，我们上了车，然后回去了。第二天早上，他们决定把前几天的糟糕经历抛在脑后。道格那天下午要在会议上发言。早上，他和凯利决定参观巴塞罗那的一座著名大教堂。现在，再被抢一次似乎运气太差了，但是……
We're coming up the steps of the Metro station, and suddenly I felt this tug at my pant leg, and I slapped the zipper pocket above my knee, and my wallet was gone. This wasn't a decoy wallet. It was the real thing, with all the cash that Doug's brother had wired him from the United States. Something snapped inside the 57-year-old neuroscientist. He was done being used as a portable ATM by European thieves. I shot my arm back. The robber hadn't gotten far. He was right behind Doug.
我们正走上地铁站的台阶，突然我感觉到裤腿被拽了一下，我拍了拍膝盖上方的拉链口袋，钱包不见了。这不是诱饵钱包。这是真的，里面有道格的哥哥从美国汇来的所有现金。这位57岁的神经科学家内心有什么东西断了。他受够了被欧洲小偷当作便携式自动取款机。我猛地向后挥动手臂。劫匪没跑远。他就站在道格身后。
He started to turn away from me, and I snagged him in the crook of my arm. He had the robber around the neck. Now what? Doug didn't have to ask himself the question. His arm seemed to know what to do. I flipped him over my hip to the ground on the pavement and jumped on his back and put him in a chokehold and then this thought bubbles up to my cerebral cortex. What are you doing?
他开始转身离开，我用手臂的弯曲处勾住了他。他把劫匪的脖子勒住了。现在怎么办？道格不需要问自己这个问题。他的手臂似乎知道该怎么做。我把他翻过我的臀部摔在人行道上，跳到他背上，对他锁喉，然后这个念头浮现在我的大脑皮层：你在做什么？
If you're robbed, you should give him the money. But I was sort of just like a spectator in this whole thing. Kelly, who was a couple of paces in front of Doug, turned around to see something she never expected to see in all her life. Wild, red, rage from her father. And I see my dad choking this random person. He has this young guy in a headlock. And I was just looking at him like what is going on?
如果你被抢了，你应该把钱给他。但我当时就像整件事的旁观者。凯利，她走在道格前面几步，转过身看到了她一生中从未想过会看到的一幕。她父亲狂野、愤怒的样子。我看到我爸爸在勒那个陌生人。他把这个年轻人锁喉了。我只是看着他，心想：发生了什么事？
Then I hear my dad yell, my wallet, and when he says my wallet, I knew instantly what had happened. Somebody had pickpocketed him again. So I'm on the ground with this guy, and he's in his 20s. I'm just thinking back to watching my kids wrestle, and I'm trying to do what they do. I'm thinking hip control, I got to keep this down, keep him pinned, and I yell, call the police, call the police, I've got him. And there's no reply. And then, from my perspective on the ground, all I saw were men's feet circling around me. And I then realized they were all part of the gang. The thief somehow managed to fling Doug's wallet
然后我听到我爸爸大喊：“我的钱包！”当他说“我的钱包”时，我立刻知道发生了什么。有人又扒了他的钱包。所以我和这家伙在地上，他才20多岁。我回想起看我孩子们摔跤的情景，我试图做他们做的事。我在想臀部控制，我必须保持这样，把他压住，我大喊：“报警，报警，我抓住他了。”没有人回应。然后，从我在地上的视角看，我只看到男人的脚在我周围盘旋。我意识到他们都是团伙成员。小偷不知怎么设法把道格的钱包
toward an accomplice. It was now Kelly's turn to do something crazy. The next thing I see is a woman's hand flying through the air and I recognize that as Kelly, Kelly was capped into the ultimate frisbee team at that time and she's doing a full-on layout on a solid concrete to deflect the disc, you know, and taps the wallet into my outstretched right hand.
扔向了一个同伙。现在轮到凯利做点疯狂的事了。接下来我看到的是一只女人的手飞过空中，我认出那是凯利。凯利当时是极限飞盘队的，她正在坚硬的混凝土上做一个完整的飞扑动作来拦截飞盘，你知道，她把钱包拍进了我伸出的右手。
Hahaha. And I sort of jump up to my feet, and I'm looking around like, okay, now what? And I see these big guys, and I watch, I follow the gaze of one of these guys. I follow his eyes as he looks down at the ground, and I see that he sees my dad's blackberry. And as I'm blocking eyes with him, I jumped on my dad's blackberry, just like a
哈哈哈。我跳了起来，环顾四周，心想：好吧，现在怎么办？我看到这些大块头，我看着，我跟随其中一个人的目光。我看着他的眼睛，他向下看着地面，我看到他看到了我爸爸的黑莓手机。当我和他目光交汇时，我扑向了我爸爸的黑莓手机，就像
football player would like grab a football or something, which is a funny image to me because it was just a blackberry. So I'm like on the ground hugging this little blackberry and I'm like, Dad, I got your phone! And I'm yelling because there's now a circle of men around me and I can see through their feet. There's a circle of men around my father as well. And he has his wallet and he knew the next move and that was to let the guy go. That's neuroscientist 2, pickpockets one.
橄榄球运动员抢橄榄球一样，这对我来说是个有趣的画面，因为那只是个黑莓手机。所以我趴在地上抱着这个小黑莓，我说：“爸爸，我拿到你的手机了！”我大喊，因为现在有一圈男人围着我，我能透过他们的脚看到。我父亲周围也有一圈男人。他拿到了钱包，他知道下一步该怎么做，那就是放走那个人。那是神经科学家2，扒手1。
When I let the band go that I had in the chokehold, he scootered away on his back, kind of like a, on his butt, sort of like a crab, and he pointed at me going, crazy man, crazy man. And now I'm staring at eye with like the ringleader and all these other guys. So what am I going to do now? I had so much adrenaline going, which I've never felt before. I was ready to throw him into his accomplices
当我放开那个被我锁喉的人时，他背着身滑走了，有点像，用屁股，像螃蟹一样，他指着我喊：“疯子，疯子。”现在我和那个头目以及其他所有人对视。我现在该怎么办？我的肾上腺素飙升，这是我从未感受过的。我准备把他扔向他的同伙
and knock him down the steps into the Larmatra station. And there was no question whether I could do that or not. There was no question whether I could do that or not. And then yeah, really pretty well dressed elderly man with a cane just sort of walks up really casually and said, yeah, he's no crazy, go. And they all fled, you know, like a bunch of birds leaving a telephone wire or something, they were just like, poof. And I'm just sort of like trying to process it all, like,
把他撞下台阶，推进地铁站。毫无疑问我能不能做到。毫无疑问我能不能做到。然后，一个穿着考究、拄着拐杖的老人很随意地走过来，说：“是的，他不是疯子，走吧。”他们全都逃跑了，你知道，就像一群鸟离开电话线一样，他们只是“噗”的一声不见了。我只是试图处理这一切，心想：
what just happened? Oh, my dad must be a spy. This is, of course, and he just like did some spy things when that guy stole his wallet. He's not really a scientist at all. Doug and Kelly stumbled away from the scene. Their hearts were racing. My dad says, you know, we have to get a knife. And I was like, what? Okay, now I'm concerned.
刚才发生了什么？哦，我爸爸一定是间谍。这当然是，他刚才在那个家伙偷他钱包时做了一些间谍动作。他根本不是什么科学家。道格和凯利跌跌撞撞地离开了现场。他们的心跳加速。我爸爸说：“你知道，我们得弄把刀。”我说：“什么？好吧，现在我担心了。”
That's like a horrible idea. On multiple levels, that's a really bad idea. You know, and I couldn't believe that my father, who I had only ever seen use knives for like cutting vegetables or firewood. It was now suggesting we need to go get a weapon. And I was sort of like, oh, okay, I need to step in and the decision-making process.
那是个可怕的主意。在多个层面上，那都是个非常糟糕的主意。你知道，我无法相信我的父亲，我只见过他用刀切蔬菜或劈柴。现在竟然建议我们需要去弄件武器。我心想，哦，好吧，我需要介入决策过程。
That's insane. We're not getting a knife. Doug was sure that they were being tracked by members of the street gang. And it turns out he was not being paranoid. He and Kelly really were being followed. And now I'm turned into a scene out of like a spy movie. We're running down back alleys.
这太疯狂了。我们不去弄刀。道格确信他们正被街头帮派成员跟踪。事实证明他并没有多疑。他和凯利确实被跟踪了。现在我变成了一个间谍电影里的场景。我们在后巷里奔跑。
We're running through restaurants, going into shops, going in one door out the back door. And so we go into a different shop and I bought this skirt so we could try and change clothing which is really bizarre and it's funny that we thought that would help and we get out of the store. And I remember seeing another person walking towards us on one side of the street and then a group of men walking towards us on the other side. And my dad just goes, we need to cross the street. Ready, go.
我们穿过餐馆，走进商店，从一个门进去，从后门出来。所以我们走进另一家店，我买了一条裙子，这样我们就可以试着换衣服，这真的很奇怪，而且很有趣，我们以为那会有用。我们走出商店。我记得看到另一个人在街的一边向我们走来，然后一群男人在另一边向我们走来。我爸爸只是说：“我们需要过马路。准备，走。”
Like no conversation. And we just started booking it across this crowded road. And we run across the street. We realized these people are following us for sure. We see them now crossing the crosswalk to come to our side of the street again. And we're like, what do we do? And he he goes let's get a taxi and we run into the street and he like hits the hood of a taxi driving by you know and he's like we need to get in.
就像没有对话一样。我们开始冲过这条拥挤的道路。我们跑过马路。我们意识到这些人肯定在跟踪我们。我们现在看到他们又穿过人行横道来到我们这边。我们心想：我们该怎么办？他说：“我们打辆出租车。”我们跑进街道，他拍打着一辆驶过的出租车的引擎盖，你知道，他说：“我们需要上车。”
When they got out of the taxi they still hadn't shaken the robbers. They jumped in another cab and asked the driver to get them the hell out of Barcelona Ben went to the next city 170-year-old cab fare I still remember It was here far outside of Barcelona Doug's heart rate started to slow. And as his normal, logical brain came back online, he couldn't believe what he had just done. He's like, I should have given them my wallet. That's crazy.
当他们下出租车时，他们仍然没有甩掉劫匪。他们跳上另一辆出租车，让司机带他们离开巴塞罗那。那是170欧元的车费，我至今还记得。就在巴塞罗那郊外，道格的心率开始减慢。当他正常的逻辑大脑恢复在线时，他无法相信自己刚才做了什么。他说：“我应该把钱包给他们的。太疯狂了。”
Why did I do that? Why was I doing that? Like, never do that. If this ever happens to you again, you know, give me your wallet. Doug's behavior disturbed him as a father, but it also disturbed him as a neuroscientist who thought he had a good handle on how the brain worked on how his own brain worked.
我为什么要那样做？我为什么要那样做？永远别那样做。如果这种事再发生在你身上，你知道，把钱包给我。道格的行为作为父亲让他感到不安，但作为一名认为自己对大脑运作方式——对自己大脑运作方式——有很好把握的神经科学家，这也让他感到不安。
From a neuroscience perspective, how does this happen that you can instantly do this aggression without even being aware and it's all unconscious? If something in my environment could cause me to suddenly risk life and limb with no conscious thought, I wanted to understand how that worked at a neuroscience level. What's going on in the brain? The question again was why evolution, which has sculpted our brains and bodies to be skilled survival machines, would preserve systems in the brain that cause us to act with unthinking haste and violence. Haste and violence that can place our own
从神经科学的角度来看，这是怎么发生的？你可以在甚至没有意识到的情况下瞬间做出这种攻击行为，而且这一切都是无意识的？如果我环境中的某些东西能导致我突然在没有意识思考的情况下冒着生命危险，我想从神经科学层面了解它是如何运作的。大脑里发生了什么？问题再次回到：为什么进化——它塑造了我们的大脑和身体成为熟练的生存机器——会保留大脑中导致我们以不假思索的匆忙和暴力行事的系统？这种匆忙和暴力可能会让我们自己的
lives at great risk. Dog eventually realized that the answer lay in the question itself. It was all about speed. The conscious brain is too slow and it doesn't have the capacity. So when you're faced with a sudden threat like a fist thrown to your chin, you have to respond faster than the conscious brain can handle it. There are lots of things that can be done slowly, but surviving an immediate threat is not one of them. When you're dealing with a predator or some other imminent danger, you have to act fast. So nature has developed high-speed pathways to the Mingala. All our senses go there before they go to the cortex, which is where we have consciousness. And that's so you can have this rapid response to a real threat.
生命处于巨大的危险之中。道格最终意识到答案就在问题本身。一切都与速度有关。意识大脑太慢了，而且没有那种能力。所以当你面临突然的威胁，比如有人向你的下巴挥拳时，你必须做出比意识大脑能处理的更快的反应。有很多事情可以慢慢做，但应对即时威胁不是其中之一。当你面对捕食者或其他迫在眉睫的危险时，你必须迅速行动。所以大自然开发了通往杏仁核的高速通路。我们所有的感官在到达皮层（我们拥有意识的地方）之前都会先到达那里。这样你就可以对真正的威胁做出快速反应。
Now we've all experienced this. You're on a basketball court and a wayward basketball comes towards you and you duck and turn and you bat it away and then you go what was that? Your unconscious mind detected because visual input went first to your amygdala, that something was in your visual space that shouldn't be there, sort of like a motion detector. But not only that, then put you on a very definitive course with a complex behavior. You think about the behavior where you turn and you intersect this thing and you bat it away. Rational thought isn't just unhelpful when that basketball is hurtling toward you.
现在我们都经历过这种情况。你在篮球场上，一个偏离方向的篮球向你飞来，你躲闪、转身、把它拍开，然后你心想：那是什么？你的潜意识发现了——因为视觉输入先到达了你的杏仁核——视觉空间里有什么不该在那里的东西，有点像运动探测器。不仅如此，它还让你进入了一个非常明确的复杂行为过程。你思考那个行为，你转身，拦截这个东西并把它拍开。当那个篮球向你飞来时，理性思考不仅无济于事。
It's actually counterproductive. Being deliberate can end up getting you smashed in the face. But short-circuiting logic creates dangers, especially when you're in the grip of an emotion like rage. You can literally stop thinking about your arm as your arm. It becomes a weapon that can be wielded, deployed, sacrificed. The brain's threat detection mechanism, which is highly controlled, to engage in a violent, aggressive interaction, risks life and limb. Most of the time, we are well-served by being logical and deliberate, but on rare occasions, it's helpful to act with unthinking haste. The operative word
它实际上适得其反。深思熟虑最终可能会让你脸部被砸。但短路逻辑会产生危险，尤其是当你处于愤怒这种情绪的控制下时。你真的可以停止把你的手臂看作你的手臂。它变成了一种可以挥舞、部署、牺牲的武器。大脑的威胁检测机制，在高度控制下，参与暴力、攻击性的互动，会冒着生命危险。大多数时候，逻辑和深思熟虑对我们很有帮助，但在极少数情况下，不假思索地匆忙行事是有帮助的。关键词
here is rare. What Doug has found is that wild, red rage erupts in very specific situations, often when you're defending your most vital interests. The brain controls this response so that it's only tripped by very specific triggers. Doug says most of these triggers are related to our basic needs. For example, you can easily imagine an animal or a human reacting with protective rage when its own life is in danger. Life from limb. If you're attacked you will fight back. There's nothing to lose. All animals will do that. Another thing most animals will do? Protect that young. You know the rule, never get
是“极少数”。道格发现，狂野、愤怒在非常具体的情况下爆发，通常是在你捍卫自己最重要利益的时候。大脑控制这种反应，使其只被非常具体的触发点触发。道格说，这些触发点大多与我们的基本需求有关。例如，你可以很容易地想象一只动物或一个人在自己的生命受到威胁时，会做出保护性的愤怒反应。生命攸关。如果你受到攻击，你会反击。没什么可失去的。所有动物都会那样做。大多数动物还会做的另一件事？保护幼崽。你知道那条规则，永远不要
between a mama bear and her cub. And while you're at it, don't try to steal her dinner. Resources. That was the other thing that was tripped when my wallet got snagged. Even a family puppy will snap at your hand if you get too close to the dish. The list goes on. Don't try to take my mate. Don't encroach on my territory.
站在母熊和幼崽之间。顺便说一句，别试图偷她的晚餐。资源。那是我的钱包被抢时触发的另一件事。即使是家养的小狗，如果你靠得太近，它也会对你的手咆哮。清单还在继续。别试图抢走我的配偶。别侵犯我的领地。
Don't corner me. If an animal is trapped, it will use aggression to break free. I mean, an animal on a trap will chew its leg off, but so will a human. These triggers remind us of a truth we cannot avoid. Humans, at the end of the day, are animals. But we're also more complicated than this list may suggest. One story that made an impression on Doug involved a man named Ray Young.
别把我逼到角落。如果一只动物被困住，它会使用攻击性来挣脱。我的意思是，被困住的动物会咬断自己的腿，人类也会。这些触发点提醒我们一个无法回避的真相：人类归根结底是动物。但我们也比这个清单所暗示的更复杂。道格印象深刻的一个故事涉及一个叫雷·杨的人。
He was 67 years old and lived in Silver Spring, Maryland, where Doug lived too. Ray was waiting his turn at a post office one day, when he saw what he thought was another customer cut the line. The next thing that happened was unbelievable. He pulled out a knife and started nifing the guy viciously. I went many of his trials and you know he had no record of violence, no rest record is completely out of character. Ray snapped because he was defending something that is of vital importance to humans. Order in society, the sky broke the rules, he cut in line.
他67岁，住在马里兰州的银泉，道格也住在那儿。雷有一天在邮局排队等候时，看到他认为另一个顾客插队。接下来发生的事情令人难以置信。他掏出一把刀，开始疯狂地刺向那个人。我参加了他的许多审判，你知道他没有暴力记录，没有犯罪记录，这完全不符合他的性格。雷失控是因为他在捍卫对人类至关重要的东西：社会秩序。那个人打破了规则，他插队了。
We all depend on a functioning social order. A stable rule following society is as essential to our survival as food and shelter. We are willing to fight to maintain such order. In social animals, in order to maintain order following the rules, aggression is what is used. That's still what we use. We use violence. Now, it's not as if every threat produces mindless rage. Plenty of people see the social order breached or get insulted
我们都依赖一个运作良好的社会秩序。一个稳定的、遵守规则的社会对我们的生存和食物、住所一样重要。我们愿意为维护这种秩序而战。在社会性动物中，为了维护秩序，遵守规则，攻击性就是被使用的手段。那仍然是我们使用的手段。我们使用暴力。现在，并不是每一个威胁都会产生无意识的愤怒。很多人看到社会秩序被破坏或受到侮辱
and don't turn into Rambo. The threshold for snapping and the drivers of violence can vary between people. You know, if you grow up in a hostile inner city, you're going to have a hair trigger because you'll be victimized if you're not. We can see those changes in the brain, but that also means you're more likely to, you know, misfire. So sometimes the right thing to do is to, you know, be the marine and charge after the threat
并没有变成兰博。失控的阈值和暴力的驱动因素在不同人之间可能有所不同。你知道，如果你在充满敌意的内城区长大，你会变得非常敏感，因为如果你不敏感，你就会成为受害者。我们可以在大脑中看到这些变化，但这也意味着你更有可能，你知道，误判。所以有时正确的事情是，你知道，成为海军陆战队员，冲向威胁。
and sometimes that's gonna get you killed. But as a species, the group as a whole will survive because somebody's gonna do one thing and somebody's gonna do something else. Doug says, Tress is often a factor in sending us over the edge. He sees Tress at play and just Cavenders responds to the arm dropper. She didn't scream and take her hands into the attacker when she first saw him. She tried to appease him.
有时这会让你丧命。但作为一个物种，整个群体会生存下来，因为总有人会做一件事，而另一些人会做别的事。道格说，压力往往是让我们崩溃的一个因素。他看到特雷斯在发挥作用，卡文德斯对持枪抢劫者做出了反应。她第一次看到袭击者时，并没有尖叫或冲向他，而是试图安抚他。
She had been enduring this for a while and stress was building and it tripped that trigger. The resource trigger. She said that it was the most valuable thing in her life that she depended on for food and everything was her camera, and they weren't going to get it. Now there is a wrong lesson you can draw from this account of rage. You could say, look, just lost it, and because she became enraged, she managed to save her camera. Doug was furious at being robbed, and his rage allowed him to take his wallet back from the Barcelona thieves. These examples suggest that rage always results in good outcomes, that you end up better off when you violently lose your temper.
她忍受这种情况已经有一段时间了，压力在不断积累，最终触动了那个触发点——资源触发点。她说，那是她生命中最宝贵的东西，是她赖以生存的食物来源，那就是她的相机，他们休想抢走。现在，从这个愤怒的案例中，你可能会得出错误的教训。你可能会说，看，她只是失去了理智，正因为她变得愤怒，她才成功保住了相机。道格因被抢劫而愤怒，他的愤怒使他从巴塞罗那的小偷手中夺回了钱包。这些例子表明，愤怒总是带来好的结果，当你暴力地发脾气时，情况会变得更好。
What this misses is that literally no one in their right mind will tell you to attack a man with a gun or to take on a street gang in a foreign country. Risking your life to save some money or to protect a camera is the very definition of crazy. When we come back, why you can't understand the deep logic of blinding rage by looking only at situations where things turn out well for you. Muhammad Boazizi was sick of the police and their demands for bribes. He was a produce seller in the city of city Bozid in Tunisia in North Africa. The harassment felt endless.
这忽略了一点，即真正理智的人绝不会建议你去攻击一个持枪的人，或者在国外去招惹街头帮派。为了省钱或保护相机而冒生命危险，这简直就是疯狂的定义。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么仅仅通过观察那些结果良好的情况，是无法理解盲目愤怒背后的深层逻辑的。穆罕默德·布瓦齐齐受够了警察及其索贿行为。他是北非突尼斯西迪布济德市的一名农产品小贩。这种骚扰似乎永无止境。
On a Friday morning in December 2010, Muhammad had an encounter with the police. Years later, there are still varying accounts of what happened. According to some, a cop confiscated the scales that Muhammad used to sell his produce. Other said, and officer wouldn't let him set up his stand. Some accounts said Muhammad was slapped or perhaps kicked. The street vendor did what citizens are supposed to do. He went to the authorities to protest his mistreatment. But when he got to the government building to larger complaint, he was barred from entry. Muhammad was gripped by an intense feeling of injustice. And then, he snapped.
2010年12月的一个周五早上，穆罕默德与警察发生了冲突。多年后，关于当时发生了什么，仍有不同的说法。据一些人说，一名警察没收了穆罕默德用来卖农产品的秤。另一些人说，警察不让他摆摊。还有说法称穆罕默德被扇了耳光，甚至可能被踢了。这位街头小贩做了公民应该做的事。他去当局抗议他所受的不公待遇。但当他到达政府大楼准备投诉时，却被拒之门外。穆罕默德被一种强烈的冤屈感所笼罩。然后，他崩溃了。
He doused himself with gasoline, standing in front of the government building that had shut the door on him. He struck a match and set himself ablaze. One of the last things onlookers heard from him were these words, how do you expect me to make a living? By the time the fire was doused and Muhammad was rushed to a hospital, Burns covered 90% of his body. He died a few weeks later. His story shows the self-destructive power of wild, red rage.
他站在将他拒之门外的政府大楼前，往自己身上浇了汽油。他划了一根火柴，引火自焚。围观者从他口中听到的最后几句话之一是：“你们让我怎么活？”当火被扑灭，穆罕默德被紧急送往医院时，烧伤面积已达全身的90%。几周后他去世了。他的故事展示了狂暴愤怒的自我毁灭力量。
But it also reveals the hidden logic of fury. Thousands of Muhammad's fellow Tunisians showed up at his funeral. On social media, he was dubbed a martyr. Members of the crowd shouted, farewell, Muhammad. We will avenge you. We weep for you today. We will make those who caused your death we. 10 days after Muhammad's death, with escalating protests around the country, the President of Tunisia ended a 23-year autocratic reign and fled the country. Within weeks, protests in Tunisia spread to other Arab countries in what came to be known as the Arab Spring. It is the end of an era in Tunisia. President Hosni Mubarak has stepped down. Libya is asking me. Neuroscientist Doug Fields has found that we are capable of fury
但它也揭示了愤怒背后隐藏的逻辑。成千上万的突尼斯同胞出现在他的葬礼上。在社交媒体上，他被称为烈士。人群中有人高喊：“再见，穆罕默德。我们会为你报仇。我们今天为你哭泣。我们会让那些导致你死亡的人哭泣。”穆罕默德去世10天后，随着全国抗议活动的升级，突尼斯总统结束了长达23年的独裁统治并逃离了该国。几周内，突尼斯的抗议活动蔓延到其他阿拉伯国家，这就是后来所说的“阿拉伯之春”。这是突尼斯一个时代的终结。胡斯尼·穆巴拉克总统已经下台。利比亚正在呼唤我。神经科学家道格·菲尔兹发现，我们有能力产生愤怒，
when we want to defend our lives or protect family or guard resources. Rage can be triggered when we want to maintain the social order. It also serves another useful purpose. Rage acts as a signaling device. If you look at the long history of social protest, it's just clear that powerful emotions like anger and rage have a huge and have had a huge role to play
当我们想要保卫生命、保护家人或守护资源时。当我们想要维护社会秩序时，愤怒也会被触发。它还有另一个有用的目的。愤怒充当了一种信号装置。如果你回顾社会抗议的悠久历史，很明显，像愤怒和狂怒这样强大的情绪，在激励人们、动员人们、将他们团结在追求正义的运动中，发挥了巨大的作用。
in galvanizing people, motivating them, bringing them together in movements towards increased justice. This is Amir Shrinivasan, a philosopher at the University of Oxford. Amir recognizes that rage does have costs, but she wants us to remember that it can be useful to communities, causes, and individuals. Anger can play this clarifying role for myself, so it can help me understand what's going on, right? It can make me come to certain kinds of moral
这是牛津大学的哲学家阿米尔·斯里尼瓦桑。阿米尔承认愤怒确实有代价，但她希望我们记住，它对社区、事业和个人是有益的。愤怒可以对我个人起到澄清作用，它可以帮助我理解正在发生的事情，对吧？它可以让我产生某种道德上的觉悟，
and political realizations I didn't have before. I come to realize there's actually an injustice at work. The benefits of anger don't stop with the clarity it brings to us as individuals. Getting angry can act as a certain kind of warning signal to other people. And in fact, there's a lot of social, psychological evidence that suggests that getting angry can be an effective means of changing other people's behavior, right? Counter to the kind of standard liberal understanding where calm group deliberation is the only way to get people to change, actually getting angry sometimes is an effective social
以及我以前没有过的政治认识。我开始意识到实际上存在着不公正。愤怒的好处并不止于它带给个人的清晰感。愤怒可以作为一种对他人发出的警告信号。事实上，有大量的社会心理学证据表明，愤怒可以成为改变他人行为的有效手段，对吧？与那种认为冷静的群体审议是改变人们的唯一途径的传统自由主义理解相反，实际上，愤怒有时是一种有效的社会信号，可以激励他人。
signal to motivate other people. In fact, Amir argues, it's important when we talk about fury to distinguish between what might be counterproductive or even harmful to individuals in the short run and the usefulness of that fury to movements, groups, and causes. Individual anger can often spread and become communal anger, and collective anger, and collective anger has extraordinary forms. She asked me to think of an example in an interpersonal setting.
事实上，阿米尔认为，当我们谈论愤怒时，区分短期内对个人可能适得其反甚至有害的行为，与这种愤怒对运动、群体和事业的有用性，是非常重要的。个人愤怒往往会蔓延并成为群体愤怒，而集体愤怒具有非凡的形式。她让我思考一个在人际关系中的例子。
Imagine the scenario, you're in a romantic relationship, and your partner cheats on you. I mean, it might be that getting angry at your cheating lover just encourages that cheating lover to cheat more. And if your lover were to say to you, well, you shouldn't get angry at me because it just makes me cheat more. I mean, that's an infuriating response, and it's infuriating because it treats your anger as just an instrument, an instrument for encouraging or discouraging his or her behavior, whereas in fact, anger, like other moral emotions, is something that makes a claim about the world.
想象一下这种情况，你处于一段恋爱关系中，而你的伴侣欺骗了你。我的意思是，对出轨的爱人发火可能只会鼓励那个出轨的爱人变本加厉。如果你的爱人对你说：“你不应该对我发火，因为这只会让我出轨更多。”我的意思是，那是一个令人愤怒的回应，它之所以令人愤怒，是因为它把你的愤怒仅仅当作一种工具，一种鼓励或阻碍他或她行为的工具，而事实上，愤怒和其他道德情绪一样，是对世界的一种主张。
An angry spouse does more than show her displeasure at infidelity. She's also sending a signal about the kind of behavior we think is appropriate in a society, in interpersonal relationships. Her anger sends a message to other spouses. Obviously, this is not happening at a conscious level. courses. Obviously, this is not happening at a conscious level. Rage can prompt you to take a stand about something and make you incur a personal cost. By short-circuiting reason, it makes you ignore those costs. Your actions might be personally harmful, but it can help the group to which you belong.
愤怒的配偶所做的不仅仅是表达对不忠的不满。她还在传递一种关于我们认为在社会和人际关系中什么是适当行为的信号。她的愤怒向其他配偶传达了一个信息。显然，这并不是在有意识的层面上发生的。愤怒可以促使你对某事表明立场，并让你付出个人代价。通过绕过理性，它让你忽视了这些代价。你的行为可能对个人有害，但它可能对你所属的群体有帮助。
This is why natural selection might conserve such behavior. We have these circuits because we need them, we have violence because unfortunately we need them. We don't call it snapping when the outcome is good. Then we call it heroism or quick thinking. One example of unthinking rage that can produce personal harms and societal benefits comes from something I've noticed on the road, including in my own behavior. Let's say I'm driving on a highway and the lane is narrowing.
这就是为什么自然选择可能会保留这种行为。我们拥有这些回路是因为我们需要它们，我们拥有暴力是因为不幸的是我们需要它们。当结果良好时，我们不称之为“崩溃”。那时我们称之为英雄主义或反应敏捷。一个可能产生个人伤害和社会利益的无意识愤怒的例子，来自我在路上观察到的情况，包括我自己的行为。假设我正在高速公路上行驶，车道正在变窄。
There's a sign that says the lane is merging left in a thousand feet. So I follow the sign and merge left. But lots of cars behind me don't merge. They zoom ahead and merge in front of me. Basically, jumping the line. I like to think of myself as a cool headed person. But in situations like this, I sometimes move my car into the side lane and hit the brakes to prevent the side zoomers from cutting ahead.
有一个标志说车道在1000英尺处向左合并。所以我按照标志向左合并。但我身后有很多车没有合并。他们加速冲到前面，合并到我前面。基本上就是插队。我喜欢认为自己是一个冷静的人。但在这种情况下，我有时会把车开到侧车道并踩下刹车，以防止侧面的插队者超车。
It's crazy. I'm not a police officer. I'm in a tiny sedan with a bunch of SUVs on my tail. But when I block these cars, I'm sending a signal, a costly signal. I'm saying, I am willing to incur personal costs to enforce a social norm. So imagine lots of people were protesting in precisely the way that you protest on the road, then it would have a huge effect on people's driving behavior, a huge positive effect on people's driving behavior. Rage in other words, can be productive not because it benefits us or our individual self-interest, but because it helps
这很疯狂。我不是警察。我开着一辆小轿车，后面跟着一堆SUV。但当我阻挡这些车时，我是在发出一个信号，一个代价高昂的信号。我是在说，我愿意付出个人代价来维护社会规范。所以想象一下，如果很多人都以你在路上抗议的方式进行抗议，那么这对人们的驾驶行为将产生巨大的影响，对人们的驾驶行为产生巨大的积极影响。换句话说，愤怒之所以能产生效果，不是因为它使我们个人受益，而是因为它帮助了
the groups to which we belong. Rage, in fact, might be one way that nature gets us to prioritize the interests of our groups over our narrow self-interest. By disabling logic and impairing reason, we can be prompted to do things that we would never do if we were only looking out for ourselves. So somebody violates a social norm and we become angry. And again, anger is prepared to fight. And as we know, sometimes these turn out tragically, people get into a fight on the road and pull out a gone. Acting in the interests of a group is not always the right or virtuous thing. Terrorist organizations
我们所属的群体。事实上，愤怒可能是大自然让我们优先考虑群体利益而非狭隘个人利益的一种方式。通过禁用逻辑和削弱理性，我们可以被促使去做一些如果我们只顾自己就永远不会做的事情。所以有人违反了社会规范，我们变得愤怒。再说一次，愤怒是为战斗做准备的。正如我们所知，有时这些结果是悲剧性的，人们在路上打架并掏出了枪。为了群体利益而行动并不总是正确或高尚的事情。恐怖组织
have long used rage as a recruiting tool for new followers. The anger of partisan politics can cause us to think more about the well-being of narrow groups like our political parties rather than the well-being of larger groups like our nation. Fury can drive massacres, wars, and genocide. All this leaves us in a bind. If we were to eliminate rage or to logically determine when to get angry, we lose the speed and potency of sudden anger. But when we allow our furies to flare unchecked, we can cause senseless damage to ourselves and others. Centuries ago, the philosopher Aristotle said,
长期以来一直利用愤怒作为招募新追随者的工具。党派政治的愤怒可能导致我们更多地考虑像政党这样狭隘群体的福祉，而不是像国家这样更大群体的福祉。愤怒可以驱动屠杀、战争和种族灭绝。这一切让我们陷入了困境。如果我们消除愤怒，或者逻辑地决定何时愤怒，我们就会失去突发愤怒的速度和效力。但当我们任由愤怒肆虐时，我们可能会对自己和他人造成毫无意义的伤害。几个世纪前，哲学家亚里士多德说：
anybody can become angry, that's easy. But to be angry with the right person, and to the right degree, and at the right time, and for the right purpose, and in the right way, that is not within everybody's power, and is not easy. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
任何人都会生气，这很容易。但要对正确的人，在正确的程度，在正确的时间，为了正确的目的，以正确的方式生气，这并不是每个人都有能力做到的，而且并不容易。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。Midrall Media是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Special thanks this week to our former producers, Raina Cohen, Parthasha and Jenny Schmidt, who played vital roles in building this episode. Audio mix by Rob Byers, Johnny Vince Evans and Michael Rayfield, a final final V2. Our unsung hero today is Damien Perry. Damien has helped me over the past year with various elements of setting up hidden brain media, our new public radio production company. He has been an invaluable source of support and strategic guidance.
我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。本周特别感谢我们以前的制片人雷娜·科恩、帕萨莎和珍妮·施密特，他们在制作这一集中发挥了至关重要的作用。音频混音由罗伯·拜尔斯、约翰尼·文斯·埃文斯和迈克尔·雷菲尔德完成，这是最终的V2版本。我们今天的无名英雄是达米安·佩里。在过去的一年里，达米安在建立我们新的公共广播制作公司——《隐藏的大脑》媒体的各个方面给予了我帮助。他一直是宝贵的支持和战略指导来源。
I think of Damien as the Swiss Army knife of consultants. He doesn't just come up with solutions to every kind of problem, but is also a constant source of kindness, humor and good cheer. We plan to collaborate with him in lots of ways in the future. Thank you Damien, for your broad talents and deep friendship. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter. Find more information about us at HiddenBrain.org. If you have a great personal story that would make for a Hidden Brain episode like the
我认为达米安是顾问中的“瑞士军刀”。他不仅能为各种问题提供解决方案，而且还是善良、幽默和愉悦的源泉。我们计划在未来以多种方式与他合作。谢谢你，达米安，感谢你的广泛才华和深厚友谊。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。在HiddenBrain.org上查找关于我们的更多信息。如果你有一个很棒的个人故事，可以制作成《隐藏的大脑》的一集，就像
story that Doug and Kelly feel still to us today, please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. If you like this episode and like our show, please tell your friends. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please show them. Next week on the show, Beyond Doom Scrolling. In a year full of truly terrible events, we consider what might be going right in the world. Thank you for listening.
道格和凯利今天向我们讲述的故事一样，请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录。通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。如果你喜欢这一集并喜欢我们的节目，请告诉你的朋友。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请教教他们。下周节目预告：超越“末日滚动”。在充满真正可怕事件的一年里，我们来思考一下世界上可能正在发生的好事。感谢收听。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。